[Music]
we come over and we're sitting at the
top talker chair then you always
introduce and you say Michelle what is
everybody talking about so if I was
answering that question today I may say
everybody's talking about missus oh you
are the headline maker lady and as a
woman who has dealt with infidelity
before yeah I think it's really
admirable and I admire the fact that
you've been so open about what you went
through with Ozzy so what do you think
that women can learn from your
experience and what you can help maybe
somebody else going through it
listen everybody's experience is
different however that when you're
married to somebody that has an
addictive personality
you know drugs drink food working out
women and it's not what women can learn
from me I think it's what couples can
learn from us is that my husband was
brave enough to come out and say hey you
caught me I need help I'm an addict with
this and this is what I'm gonna do and
he's been you know in long-term
treatment for this and we speak about we
laugh about it because it helps you get
through it because otherwise it would be
like you know the curtain scene in
psycho but it's no I'm joking with the
Hat do you know it's you have to find
some humor in something right and so you
know we're always you know making silly
jokes about it but the bottom line is is
that I love him he loves me
we've been together we're in our 36 year
right now but I've known him for 40
years
and in 40 years is he honestly gonna
turn around and say I've never been with
another woman I'm 40 years no so it's
life happens not did not exclusive to me
an Aussie the differences is that he
he's the one taking the heat
not me and he's brave enough to deal
with it good I want to know because so
many people break up over things like
that why you think you guys have been
able to make it because I lived without
him and I'm much happier with him than
without him and we've worked with so
much together we've achieved so much
together our family our friends and I
just don't want to give that up
[Music]
you